good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock welcome to the breakfast show
here on the sky revealed this morning
the damning claims from a whistleblower
about the evacuation from afghanistan
and how it was handled by the foreign
office the government is accused of
being unprepared for the cries for help
from afghans at risk because of their
links to the uk
some of those afghans it's alleged
have now been murdered we'll talk to the
man in charge at the time the former
foreign secretary and now justice
secretary dominic raab in just a few
moments
also on the show the shadow attorney
general emily thornbury former shadow
foreign secretary what does she make of
it all plus
remember this from yesterday the
republican congressman criticized for
posting a picture of himself
and his family posing with guns just
days after four teenagers were killed in
a high school shooting in michigan what
on earth was he thinking i'm going to be
talking about that in more detail at
half past the hour
and from the shores of the maldives
to life in loch lomond we'll meet the
sea turtle april who's been given the
chance of a new beginning in scotland
after being found entangled in a net in
the indian ocean
there she is blesser it's tuesday the
7th of december
left to die the damning claims from a
whistleblower who says that junior
government officials working on the
afghanistan evacuation were asked to
make life and death decisions they knew
nothing about
we're live here in county cork in
ireland where a red threat to life
warning is now in place a storm barra
arrives
i'm in eschat in northumberland where
nearly 500 homes are still without power
this morning following storm irwin
[Music]
i'm live at gatwick as travellers face
more expensive pre-departure testing
from today while arrivals from nigeria
have to enter hotel quarantine in the
battle to beat omicron
olympic boycott what will the uk do
after the u.s says it won't send
government officials to next year's
beijing winter games over human rights
concerns
and is it last orders from the porn star
martini why one of britain's most iconic
cocktails may be on its way out but why
[Music]
disturbing news this morning from a
whistleblower who worked in the foreign
office during the fall of kabul he's
claimed that failures made by the
government during the withdrawal from
afghanistan led to people being left to
die
at the hands of the taliban the
government is accused of being
unprepared for a huge number of cries
for help from afghans at risk because of
their links with the uk
the claims will be made in written
evidence presented to the foreign
affairs select committee later on today
it's alleged that junior officials were
left to make hundreds
hundreds of life and death decisions
that they knew nothing about and emails
were only marked as read so those in
charge could say there were no unread
emails we'll be talking to the former
foreign secretary dominic raab he's now
the justice secretary and of course
deputy prime minister who was in charge
at the time
first our middle east correspondent
alastair bunkel reports
nato's 20 years in afghanistan ended in
chaos as thousands of afghans
desperately tried to escape now a
whistleblower has given an incendiary
account of how the foreign office
responded as kabul fell to the taliban
and it isn't good
rafael marshall a former desk officer
claims that confusion bureaucracy and
disorganization meant people were left
behind
many of these people he says would have
since been murdered by the taliban
among the allegations marshall says that
between seventy five thousand to a
hundred and fifty thousand people
applied for evacuation but fewer than
five percent of those actually received
any assistance he also claims that no
member of the team working on these
cases had studied afghanistan
worked on afghanistan previously or had
a detailed knowledge of afghanistan and
more damning still he alleges that
evacuation requests in the foreign
office inbox were read but not recorded
or responded to
and in his assessment that was so that
the prime minister and the foreign
secretary could say that there were no
unread emails mr marshall reserves his
most devastating criticism for dominic
raab the former foreign secretary who
was holiday in crete when kabul fell
he alleges that despite the desperate
situation at kabul airport mr rob took
hours to engage with evacuation requests
before returning the files and asking
for them to be resubmitted in an easier
to read spreadsheet
speaking to sky news in august dominic
raab defended the speed and the
efficiency of the withdrawal so the
system is operating at full speed
at full capacity and we'll use every
last remaining hour and day to get
everyone we can back that we want to
make sure we use every last hour and day
to keep this rate up marshall also says
that the prime minister personally
intervened to secure the evacuation of
animals in the care of british charity
worker pen farthing and that was at the
expense of afghans at imminent risk of
execution by the taliban the chair of
the foreign affairs select committee tom
tugenhardt said in a statement that
these allegations are serious and go to
the heart of the failures of leadership
around the afghan disaster which we have
seen throughout this inquiry these
failures betrayed our friends and allies
and squandered decades of british and
nato effort mr marshall's claims point
the finger directly at whitehall
dysfunction and they also raised the
question of whether failures at the
heart of government could have had
deadly consequences
uncle sky news
well the justice secretary deputy prime
minister former foreign secretary
dominic raab is here good morning to you
did you as a government
really prioritize dogs
over people to get them out of
afghanistan i think you can see that we
didn't do that because in two weeks we
pulled off and it was a joint effort
foreign office home office mod the
evacuation of 15 000 people that's just
in two weeks that is the biggest
evacuation and living memory the only
country that got more people out was the
united states and it took an absolutely
heroic and herculean effort to achieve
that under incredibly difficult
conditions didn't make doesn't mean that
you didn't prioritize dogs over people
apparently uh the quote the written
statement that will be given to the
house uh to a house of commerce
committee later on is that
they received an instruction from the
prime minister use considerable capacity
to get these dogs uh out of afghanistan
sorry it's just not accurate we of
course didn't that's a lie we did not
put uh the welfare of animals above uh
individuals uh and i think you can see
that in the facts of 15 000 people
evacuated in just two weeks as i said
biggest uh effort operation and living
memory uh and only the us got more out
that's a lie
that he said that i'm not accusing
anyone of lying i'm just correcting the
facts okay um he also went on to say
this uh young guy who is a desk officer
25 years old said there were 75 to 100
000 please for help less than 5
were helped
do you recognize those figures i i don't
but what is certainly true
is that we had a lot of people rushing
to get out of afghanistan for all sorts
of reasons and i think it's right that
we had a process in place to check two
things one that were helping those at
genuine risk of persecution or british
nationals or people who would work for
the british government and secondly
making sure um that we didn't allow
anyone to come into the uk who might
present a threat to the uk and it was
important to have a process to make
those decisions swiftly but also
accurately so it was important to uh to
in order to make sure that people didn't
come into the uk who perhaps shouldn't
be coming in that they were left behind
to be murdered
no that's not what i'm saying but i
think anyone would expect us to conduct
the basic checks the basic checks and
the real challenge in the evacuation uh
was the operational situation on the
ground so getting people to the airport
that was extremely difficult and
secondly verifying identity and of
course you've got to verify identity to
make sure you're helping those who are
genuinely most at risk and also at the
same time just checking we're not uh
through that generosity of spirit
letting anyone in that might harm the uk
but you accept that some of those who
have been left behind have been murdered
look i think it's an incredibly
difficult situation
we would have wanted a longer time
window
in order to get out
everyone who was eligible but even after
the evacuation i saw this myself
we were working to get flights out of
kabul with qatar we were working with
regional partners to make sure that we
could take british nationals and those
that we had said that we would take we
did everything we could and again i say
come back to the point 15 000 people
evacuated in two weeks uh
never been done before certainly not in
my living memory and only the united
states got more people out i think
i think that was actually a record that
those involved particularly those
working on the ground should be proud of
so a longer timeline could have saved
lives we've always said that we're up
against this timeline uh that a
combination of the us deadline uh and
the taliban's approach to it that we're
working to an expedited deadline and
look that put pressure on the evacuation
plan but we've been planning for this uh
since well before since january um and
indeed again in april we changed the
travel advice uh those schemes like the
app scheme were being set up but of
course if we'd have had extra time we
would have
prolonged that
well
and as a result of the change you've got
to adapt to the changing situation on
the ground the taliban takeover and at
that point
we continued to work with our partners
qatar to get further flights with
british nationals and others that worked
for us out we also worked with the
partners on the borders both in the
uzbekistan
pakistan we did everything we could but
you have to have some form of process
again otherwise you're not going to be
letting in those who are most at need of
your help and also i think the public
and people watching this would expect us
to check that we don't have anyone
coming into the uk who pose a threat to
us it's important that i put some more
of these allegations that will be will
develop during the course of the day to
you then you get an opportunity to reply
um he also said the whistleblowers we'll
call him um accused you of sending back
information that had been sent to you
because it was about people that you
wanted to get out of afghanistan because
you wanted it better presented in a
spreadsheet
that's not quite right but what is
absolutely true to say with the volume
of applications we were considering we
wanted to make sure we had the basic
facts in order to make clear decisions i
think the charge that was leveled as it
took several hours to make these
decisions not weeks
not days even several hours i think it's
right to take the time and it was
something that i was doing with the home
secretary the defense secretary
depending on the category case to make
sure that we're helping those who are
eligible those that really needed our
help or those that were british
nationals and not allowing in those that
might threaten the country he says that
people died because you wanted a
spreadsheet it's just not correct
okay um did you and the pm mislead
parliament by
falsely saying that emails had been read
when they hadn't by ticking them as read
when they hadn't been
so every email that was ticked as read
and had been read by somebody who could
perhaps have made a difference well i
can't vouch for every
action of every official in relation to
every email but certainly uh i i've uh
never asked for uh emails to be ticked
as read that weren't read okay uh he
also went on to say that at times the
only person dealing with the desperate
emails were junior officials and on one
occasion he was the only person that was
working on these emails well we had a uh
a thousand people from the in the
foreign office alone uh looking at these
and of course the foreign office was the
repository for applications uh for arab
uh for the special cases as well as for
questions of british nationality um so
it was a a a challenge but we had across
whitehall teams a thousand foreign
office officials working uh on the
evacuation a whole range of home office
people and mod people working on them
and of course
it's not just a question of answering
the emails it's when they and there are
many duplicated claims it's making sure
that you have a process that can swiftly
but accurately decide those claims that
was where the focus was he talks about
the culture at the foreign office and
the fact that people would only work
their set hours of eight hours others
were working from home and as a result
junior officials were being left to make
life or death decisions i i don't accept
that characterization would and i know
that's not true but i know officials are
going to be giving evidence to the
foreign affairs committee later on but i
regularly checked that we were properly
resourced but the challenge of course
with all of these things was the
verification of the facts on the ground
so if you have a lot of undocumented
people coming forward and saying either
they're a british national or that
they're uh qualified with special cases
scheme you've got to find a process
which can clarify the facts the basic
facts in order to make an informed
decision if you'd had more staff working
more hours you could have done that
quicker and potentially save lives well
and it's exactly that point i think the
the inherent challenge of getting
factual questions in relation to
undocumented people applying for the
three different schemes that were uh
available i i
you know that is inherent i don't think
having extra staff in london would have
particularly made that easier the
challenge was
deciphering the facts on the ground as
well as the second operational challenge
which was making sure we could get to
the airport in kabul uh safe passage
given the very difficult conditions
there to that end apparently um one
computer for eight soldiers on the
ground they all had to use it to try to
uh verify facts in order to get people
to the airport do you recognize that i
know that would be a
that would have been an issue for the
mod but uh all i can tell you if that
was the case well how do you feel about
that don't know
i'm trying to answer the questions and
the facts that as as i know them but all
i'd say is yeah but one computer eight
soldiers when you're trying to get tens
of thousands of people out in a very
very well the soldiers aren't are
primarily there to be behind
a computer but there were mod home
office officials foreign office staff
but the point i would make is that
actually the troops on the ground did an
incredible job but so did the other
backup uh officials whether they were
home office nationality or border staff
and of course the foreign office uh led
by lori bristow do you recognize the
allegation that at times there was just
one junior official on the desk trying
to process all of these emails no i
don't i mean and if that were to be the
case how would you feel well again i
don't answer hypothetical questions what
i know is that i i mean i certainly
regularly checked with nigel casey and
we're the the relevant director of uh
the team who did a brilliant job in my
view um and the officials that we were
properly resourced as i said i think
you're confident that you were i think i
think uh if i may say so that the and i
understand why if you're a relatively
junior desk officer it would have felt
like you're under a lot of pressure the
inherent challenge that we had was the
situation on the ground uh in kabul the
challenge of deciphering and working out
who was eligible who was not and then
getting to the them to the airport
safely we got 15 000 people out um and i
think that others stayed behind and died
well and this is true for i think for
all of the western countries that were
there we were right it doesn't it
doesn't and uh but but it does show you
that we did everything we could because
we haven't seen an evacuation like that
in living memory and no other country i
mean the u.s is the only other country
and they were there on a greater scale
that got more people out okay there is
going to be an investigation it was
launched in august uh an internal
inquiry when will we see the results of
that
the the internal inquiry yeah into what
happened uh yeah his evidence or was so
serious apparently that an entire
internal inquiry was launched in august
we haven't seen the results of that year
well that's uh that's something that the
following the deputy prime minister yes
but of course we've got a team effort
here and i'm sure the foreign office
will uh give the full timeline when they
give evidence to the foreign affairs
select committee later on today okay you
lost your job as a result of what
happened
reflection do you think that's fair i
don't think that's true um and i know i
did everything i possibly could and
again i point to the facts that we and
not just the 15 000 in that two weeks we
we secured the safe passage of 17 000
people if you take the period uh from
april which shows you that we've been
planning uh since well before um the the
august evacuation and the taliban take
over why do you think you lost your job
well uh those are decisions for the
prime minister but i um uh i'm pretty
confident from what he said to me that
it wasn't in relation to afghanistan
and of course today then potentially you
know
we may be looking at that again do you
think
no
but uh these aren't my calls i serve at
the pleasure of the prime minister okay
talk to me uh before i let you go
because i know that we are almost out of
time
um talk to me about what on earth
happened at this party that we keep
hearing about at number 10. on sunday
you said that police don't normally
quoting you don't normally look back and
investigate things that have taken place
a year ago yesterday we had the policing
minister on the program he said we
should be investigating anything that is
a historic crime to them the police
should be investigating that where are
we today well so my quote was directly
from what the metropolitan police said
this is a matter for them they said that
in relation to covid regulations they
wouldn't routinely investigate a
retrospective breaches so i was simply
uh pointing to what the police
themselves have said number 10 have been
very clear there was no party there's
been no breach of the rules and frankly
i appreciate i've asked this answer the
questions from you answer questions on
sunday which i'm very happy to do but i
don't have anything further to add it's
pretty categorical yeah i understand
that deputy prime minister final
question on it though before i let you
go if i may and that is that we're still
talking about it you know 10 days in
why doesn't why doesn't the prime
minister or you pull the police in and
say have a look at this and then we can
say yeah it's you know our hands are
clean wait for the police to decide what
they do and the
prime minister
the police could ask the prime minister
could ask the police to look at it well
to be honest with you it's for the
police they've already had uh the the
facts sent to them they've already had
uh they've well we've seen two labour
mps ask um for it and they've made clear
in the but it's ultimately a matter for
the police and just on the fundamental
point number 10 have been very clear
there was no party and there were no
rules breached okay it's good to talk to
you good to talk to you let you go thank
you very much indeed thank you
well let's talk about look at uh how the
newspapers are reflecting that the
guardian features the evidence of that
former diplomat from the foreign office
who insists that uk government
bureaucracy left afghans to die
when they couldn't escape during the
fall of kabul the male has the same lead
story the times quotes experts who say
omicron will be the dominant strain of
covid in the uk within weeks the i hears
that despite the new variant the
government is confident there won't need
to be a plan b for restrictions over
christmas but the telegraph says the
opposite reporting the boost of vaccine
rollout is at a standstill
going to be talking uh about what we
heard there from the deputy prime
minister in just a few moments time but
before that it's been described as one
of the worst storms to hit the british
isles this century and severe weather
warnings have been issued as storm barra
closes in from the atlantic today but it
comes with many homes in the uk still
disconnected in the wake of storm aarwin
the prime minister has expressed his
concern that hundreds of households in
the north of england remain without
power but says he's been assured that
the lights will be back on for the
remaining 500 homes by the end of today
so what's in store while storm barrow
will bring gale force winds of up to 80
miles an hour affecting most of the uk
yellow snow warnings are in place for
scotland and northern england and very
windy conditions are expected across
britain with severe coastal gales
and there's a yellow warning for rain
and wind in northern ireland extending
to central ireland the irish met office
has ensured as issued rather a warning
for even stronger winds in coastal areas
and a red warning in the south west
well our island correspondent stephen
murphy is in kinsale in county cork for
us and fraser moore is in rothbury in
northumberland stephen um to you first
of all i can see from the colour on your
jacket there that the winds are picking
up
yeah i mean it's been this way here
since about six o'clock this morning
that's when that red warning as you say
kicked into effect we're here in county
court and also in neighboring county
kerry as well there's another one on the
way for claire a bit further up the
atlantic coast uh that starts at about 4
p.m they're very rare these red warnings
and the net
uh office here in ireland met aaron as
it's called has said that it is a threat
to life these winds have been picking up
they're gusting up to 130 kilometers per
hour that's 80 miles per hour we've
already had one here in cork recorded
this hour of 113 kilometers an hour
that's about 70 miles per hour all of
that is expected to bring flying debris
down trees down power lines the police
are urging everybody to stay at home
where possible schools are shut here and
in 11 other counties around ireland as
well there's a yellow warning across the
entire country and an orange warning in
many other
counties as well the t-shirt the prime
minister miho martin has said today is
going to be a very difficult day apart
from the wind threat there's also the
threat of flooding and in cork city
which is about 30 minutes north of here
they are expecting a high tide any time
now 7 24 a.m the council are very
concerned about the threat to businesses
and residents in cork city we were there
yesterday they were handing out hundreds
and hundreds of sandbags so all of this
uh is predicted to last for the entire
day and into tomorrow and then of course
it's going to push across uh the irish
sea into wales and the rest of britain a
bit later on today okay
okay thanks uh meantime let's let's
bring it thanks a lot um we'll chat to
you in the next hour fraser um what on
earth is happening in the northeast
they've been without power for days and
days and days
11 days now it is getting excruciating
for those people who are still without
power there's around 500 households k uh
still waiting to be reconnected northern
power grids say that this is their final
push to try and make that happen at the
moment we are in the calm before the
storm there's no wind here at all the
temperature's about zero or one degrees
it's actually doesn't feel too bad but
as soon as the wind starts to pick up as
storm barrow begins to come across from
ireland
over into into mainland england then
we're going to see uh much more
problematic conditions for those workers
who are trying to restore power just for
example uh one
one scene yesterday we were there for
four or five hours watching one of the
crews trying to repair a transformer it
took them that long they were still
working away when we left in the dark
and they weren't expected to uh to
reconnect power for at least another
couple of hours after we left that was a
crew trying to restore that took that
amount of time and at the end of it only
about three homes were going to be put
back onto the grid again so that's the
problem that they're facing 500
properties but many of them are isolated
and many of them will require a lot of
work in very difficult conditions just
to restore connect to just to reconnect
the power to a handful of homes at each
location so northern power grids say
they are well staffed they're well
resourced to carry out this final push
they are confident that they'll get
those remaining 500 homes back on the
grid by the end of today but of course
the problem is that was the winds start
to pick up we'll see uh more challenging
conditions for them we saw an example of
this at the weekend some homes have been
reconnected uh after being without power
for seven or eight days and then a fresh
snowfall on saturday meant that a lot of
them lost their power again and that's
the danger that's the fear today okay
gentlemen thank you storm irwin giving
way to storm barrow we're across it for
you still to come on the programme for
you this morning at just after eight
we'll hear from labour's emily thornbury
in her new role as shadow attorney
general
what do you make of this christmas card
goodness me from a republican
congressman in the united states we'll
be chatting about whether it's
distasteful
later in the hour
talking to a women's rights campaigner
as the government's legal review body
recommends criminalizing material
inciting violence against women and
girls
and new travel restrictions have come
into force this morning as the uk
tightens its border policy amid concerns
over the omicron variant anyone age 12
and over wishing to travel to the uk
must show a negative pre-departure test
either a lateral flow or a pcr within 48
hours of departure after arriving in the
uk travelers will have two days to take
a pcr test and they'll have to isolate
until they receive those results
nigeria is the latest country to be
added to the truffle the travel red list
which has tougher entry rules
only british or irish nationals or uk
residents are allowed to enter the uk
from these countries
they'll have to pay to quarantine for 10
days in a hotel
well katie barnfield is at gatwick for
us this morning hello to katie and it's
not been going as smoothly as the
government might have hoped has it
no okay well i mean i think it's fair to
say there has been fury from the travel
industry about the introduction of these
new restrictions after the association
of british travel agents has said they
think it could be a devastating blow to
what is already a struggling industry
they're worried because of course these
rules apply to everybody over 12 coming
into the uk even if they're double or
even triple vaccinated and of course
passengers have got to pay for these
tests themselves which they are worried
could put a lot of people off we heard
um i mean of course this is this has
been brought into combat uh the new
omicron coronavirus variant we heard
last night from the health secretary
sajid javid saying that omicron is now
spreading within communities within the
uk in various places without any links
to international travel so it does beg
the question
how effective is it going to be
introducing these new restrictions now
and as you mentioned 11 countries uh now
on the uk's travel red list nigeria the
latest to be added to much upset from
nigerian officials yesterday calling it
saying it's amounted to travel apartheid
but the government is saying uh it's now
going to increase hotel capacity for
anyone else who has to come in and
quarantine in case it needs to add more
countries to that red list
okay thanks very much thanks for the
update apparently doubling the number of
hotel rooms that will be available going
to cost you a fortune if you have to
stay there for 10 days now
did you expect to see the spandau ballet
and eastenders star martin kemp dressed
up as father christmas in a vaccine
centre this morning well if not you're
in for a treat
this winter vaccinations are the best
form of protection to keep ourselves and
our loved ones safe
in a new campaign video released by the
nhs kemp dresses up as santa and goes
about his usual chores which include
booking his sleigh in for an mot
polishing his boots and of course
picking up his jab he says it's quick
and easy to fit in over the festive
period and urge the public to get it
ticked off their own to-do list
let's take a look at some of the other
stories making news for you this morning
here on the programme the u.s president
joe biden will hold a video call with a
russian president vladimir putin later
on today amid growing concern over the
build-up of russian troops on the
ukrainian border it follows a call
between leaders from the uk u.s france
italy and germany yesterday in which
boris johnson called for a united front
in the face of a mounting russian threat
a new study suggests viagra could be
used to treat alzheimer's researchers
say the impotence drug was associated
with a 69 reduced risk of the condition
tests in cells suggest the drug targets
some of the proteins that accumulate in
the alzheimer's type of dementia
the united states has announced that it
will not send any official delegates to
the winter olympics in china next year
still waiting to hear what the brits are
going to do about that our asia
correspondent tom cheshire standing by
for us um hello to you tom does this
matter to the chinese
i mean they say it doesn't matter okay
but given the reaction we've already had
in beijing i think it does it's been a
pretty furious one even before this
boycott was announced uh they were
attacking the idea and saying they
hadn't even invited u.s officials so it
wasn't up to them to decide but we've
just had a press conference um here from
the ministry of foreign affairs where
they respond to this directly and they
accused um they said this idea that the
lie of the century of genocide in
xinjiang was fabricated by the u.s that
was the reason given by the s for why it
wouldn't attend because of what it says
is a genocide happening against the
uyghur people and other minorities in
xinjiang and other human rights abuses
and the u.s also saying he didn't want
to join the fanfare of the olympics and
the chinese went on to say that what the
us is doing was counter to the olympic
charter principle that sport should
maintain political neutrality uh that's
something that china said all the way
through i think one of the other things
that added to this cause for a
diplomatic boycott the u.s athletes will
still be there
was actually the treatment of an athlete
it was pong shui the tennis player a
former chinese olympian she alleged that
she was sexually assaulted by a very
senior communist party official and then
she seemed to disappear from view only
to reappear on what like like quite
stage managed appearances on chinese
state media i think that added to the
calls uh that there shouldn't be this
official representation which would be
taken perhaps as an endorsement of the
chinese government but as you say we're
now in a position where we won't have
u.s officials we don't know if there
will be british officials they haven't
made a decision yet a public decision in
any case new zealand has said they won't
send uh officials so is lithuania but
we're still waiting to see what the
british government does and whether it
follows the us in this diplomatic
boycott okay thank you thanks a lot
now is it the end as we know it of one
of britain's most beloved beverages
there are fears that the iconic porn
star martini might become the latest
casualty of climate change the boss of
revolutionary bars which sells over a
million porn star martinis every year
told a zero carbon forum that they are
getting rid of the iconic passion fruit
slice and replacing it with a sheet of
rice paper
rob pictures said that the slice is
usually imported across the atlantic
from south america only to be removed
and thrown away by customers as soon as
they receive the drinks so as a result
uh they is at the end of the porn star
martini i shouldn't keep saying that if
you're watching kids at home ask your
mum quick look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather sponsored by qatar airways
the irish met service has issued a red
wind warning for cork and kerry and
orange warnings for other coastal areas
island is mostly wet and very windy with
severe coastal gales and some mountain
snow uk meanwhile is mainly fine and
frosty although it's windy in the
southwest bearing in mind that that is
coming west look at that you're going to
be needing your brolly basically
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now this if you're doing your christmas
shopping in london over the weekend may
have spotted a mysterious figure
patrolling the streets
this is sea greed a norwegian forest cat
who apparently gets quite a kick out of
roaming the streets of soho in her bike
with her owner travis we're also hearing
that she popped into some of her
favorite clothes stores including
mouse of fraser
i can't do the other one let's stick
with most of fraser coming up after the
break the christmas card that's got
everybody talking perhaps not for the
right festive reasons that to come
[Music]
hello again you are waking up this
morning to a bombshell of written
evidence that will be presented in front
of a parliamentary committee later on
today by a junior desk officer
at the foreign office during what
happened in afghanistan and ali is here
as you can see good morning ali my
goodness me it will make for
uncomfortable reading for the prime
minister and others yeah uncomfortable
reading i think particularly for dominic
rob who you spoke to this morning who
was a foreign secretary and a lot of
this evidence from the whistleblower was
aimed squarely at dominic rob he was
accused of being too slow of taking too
long to read the notes about these
people that were desperate to be
evacuated from afghanistan now he
defended himself this morning by saying
that those decisions take time he needed
to take hours because people had to be
verified their identity he said that
they acted as quickly and as accurately
as they could and he said that the
evacuation effort was a record people
should be proud of but i don't think
that that is the account that people are
going to be hearing about the
allegations that emails were marked as
read even though the whistleblower says
they weren't and the prime minister sent
a note quoting the note saying that dogs
should be prioritized over people
he pretty directly refuted a lot of what
we heard from the whistleblower he said
that he didn't recognize that account he
said that he regularly checked that the
um the staffing was properly resourced
because of course the biggest question i
think with all of this were about the
fact that we have a 25 year old man here
rafael marshall who said that he was
left alone at one moment to monitor this
inbox with thousands of emails coming in
from people who want to be
evacuated from afghanistan people who
had um worked alongside uk troops even
if they weren't directly working for the
british government who were left to die
he said now the foreign secretary said
that that wasn't the case then foreign
secretary then foreign secretary now the
justice secretary said that that wasn't
the case he said uh that he was checking
everything was properly resourced he
said he didn't recognize that account
that junior people were left alone to
monitor but i think this is a pretty
credible
witness and a very difficult day for the
now justice secretary donna mcrob yeah
and also for the prime minister uh we'll
take your take on it at nine o'clock yes
look forward to it thanks very much
indeed thanks a lot pretty damning stuff
in uh that written statement that we'll
hear much more about uh later on uh
today the former foreign secretary
dismissing out of hand almost everything
that that junior desk officer as he
described him has said saying that he
could see why as a junior desk officer
might feel overwhelmed
now a u.s congressman has faced
criticism after he posted a christmas
photograph of his family posing with
military-style guns just days after a
deadly shooting in michigan
kentucky's republican representative
thomas massey tweeted the photo with the
caption merry christmas
ps santa please bring ammo
joining us now us political commentator
and journalist scotty nell hughes and
democratic analyst and attorney ari
aramesh thank you both for joining us um
scotty to you first of all if i may this
didn't seem very smart
well i'm not going to defend that
christmas card i mean i do think that it
was very ill-advised it was very
insensitive it was foolish but kay i
would say that about anything that
involves guns and a type of any sort of
promotion because guns are serious
they're not toys
and they're not props but i would say
that whether you were talking about
yesterday six weeks ago or six months
ago but i think what you're doing i
think it's absolutely absurd to compare
it and even draw on this idea that we
had the horrible tragedy that happened
at the school shooting and drawing that
somehow that connection to the kentucky
congressman's very ill-advised posting
and i think that is what is the problem
with the argument about proper gun
control proper this sort of logical
common sense handling of guns in america
today is because it becomes so quickly
polarized that people go to the opposite
ends and refuse to have a conversation
because of literally the attack that's
going on on congressman massey for this
one
okay arie what do you think
well congressman matthew is a troll and
the problem with trolls in the
republican party is that they gain
popularity just like congresswoman
marjorie taylor green uh the more uh
friends you become because of the club
because of the primary system and
because of the
uh districts that are so non-competitive
if you look at the 435 congressional
districts and if you look at those
districts within republican held states
very few maybe a few fewer than a
handful actually competitive so in these
primaries for republicans like
massey of kentucky's fourth
congressional district he's not gonna
face a challenge from a moderate
republican and he's not gonna face a
real meaningful challenge from a
democrat in the general he's gonna face
a challenge if any from his friends
right so massey who votes against
anti-lynching laws who compares the
vaccine mandate to the holocaust which
for which it took a lot of blame and
criticism rightly so for massey who
votes against
giving medals to capital police officers
who fought against insurrectionists and
insurrectionists and thugs who attacked
the capital
these are all not even dog whistles
these are just whistles to the uh to the
base of his party and to the base of his
supporters and it helps if a troll
can send out a christmas card like this
just because it's legal it doesn't make
it right it's legal to drink a thousand
cups of coffee a day it doesn't make it
right it would be legal to send a
christmas part
and tweet it with full of sex toys but
they wouldn't make it right again uh
we're not even gonna get into the topic
of whether it's sensitive enough or not
it's just that he's a troll he knows by
doing this just like many other members
of the republican party the leader of
the party president trump himself he
will gain more following and it will
gain more headlines and that's exactly
why we're sitting here talking about the
fourth district of kentucky's
representative congressman congressman
massey mind you by the way he might be a
troll but he's an mit grad he knows
better i need to let scotty come back in
there if i may scotty go on
but that's the problem this is why we're
having the conversation right now if you
listened to ahri's conversation it was
all about everything that is wrong about
what republicans do and i agree like i
said this was an ill-sensitive and the
issues that congressman massey does the
key is he represents a very strong part
of the republican base and there are
people that agree that their second
amendment rights are under attack and
that ammunition right now is being
limited in the american public that's a
fact that is something that a lot of
republicans stand strong behind but to
consider him a troll and say not point
out the own it's like let me look at the
splinter in your eye when you're looking
at absolutely the two by four that
exists within the democrat party's eyes
ilian omar alicia a casio cortez all of
them the entire democratic party in a
lot of ways can be considered one big
party of trolls that take a simple truth
and twist it in order and weaponizes it
rather than have a conversation and talk
about the good things that we are
learning that is coming out of the
situation about how we're talking about
parents should be held accountable when
their children are involved in school
shooting all the things that we could
actually build legitimate solutions for
democrats are quick to try to see how
they can politicize how they can
capitalize on the situation in order to
go after their opponents that is not
right that it's not healthy but
unfortunately that's american politics
before we let you go
both go was there not necessarily in the
right order uh arie uh will the
democrats capitalize on this
well first of all
uh the fine lady on the other side
cannot name one single law or
legislation in the past 10 years or 20
for that matter that has limited gun
rights that has limited ammunition so
let's let's see
if we talk about when we talk either an
interruption
when we talk about
actual gun laws we're talking about you
know facts versus fiction so the right
wing and republicans talk about the
fiction of gun control when it really
doesn't exist second uh when we compare
ilhon omar and aoc to someone who sits
there with
fully automatic and semi-automatic uh
weapons with his children when we
compare that someone who compares the
holocaust to uh vaccines someone who
knows better being the person
again i didn't i didn't i didn't
interrupt you i did not go on and on
and it's not and it's not this is not
russia tv let me just finish my point so
uh but
that right there is is what is the
problem with the company let me finish
if you let me finish nelly if you let me
finish bottom line is this we have a
very even have enough respect for me as
a female to learn my name ari talk about
sexism being displayed right here where
i actually know your name but you're
quick on the actual digs at me that's
the problem right there
this is if i may finish my points if i
may finish my point the problem with
this is trolls in congress and trolls in
the republican party
win votes because the base of the
republican party is exactly very much
pro and very much sort of meanable to
this kind of rhetoric and this is why
and unfortunately the discussion becomes
so venomous the discussion becomes so
poisonous where you actually stand up
and point out the fact that these sorts
of things are wrong
you just get this sort of you know uh
what about us and then what about on the
other side what about on the other side
then you see that
sadly we are out of time absolutely
fascinating debate please come back and
debate um other issues for us together
very soon so sorry we're out of time i'd
love to hear more from you thank you
very much
now eu health ministers are meeting in
brussels this morning as covert cases
surge in europe it comes as countries
across the continent take steps to curb
the spread in france nightclubs have
been ordered to close for four weeks to
combat rising cases hospitals have begun
declaring emergency protocols as bed
space begins to fill up the prime
minister said that yesterday stricter
social distancing and extended use of
face masks will be required in schools
as well he said slovakia's health
minister says we'll ask the cabinet to
extend a lockdown by another week the
country has been in the grip of one of
the world's worst coronavirus waves in
the past few weeks last month it
introduced a lockdown that shot most
shops and services
italy has introduced tougher coronavirus
restrictions as the government there
tries to cope with a fresh wave of the
virus and the new omicron variant
yesterday saw the launch of the super
green pass only those who've been
vaccinated are allowed at sports events
concerts theaters indoor restaurants
and public events that was introduced
yesterday nbc's claudia lavanga is in
rome for us
claudia hello to you well okay well just
as you said it uh
yes hi hi kay um well just as you were
mentioning the from the green pass we've
moved on to the super green pass well at
least until a couple of days ago people
who are not vaccinated could have just
gone and take a negative test to get
into places like the one behind me so
restaurants or bars and sit down there
or theaters and cinemas and all the
other places you listed uh in your
introduction well no longer at least
until january the 15th as you mentioned
you will need to be vaccinated actually
fully vaccinated or you will have to be
recovered from covet within the last six
months if you want to go into those
other pla into these places like that or
public entertainment places well on top
of that um you also will need a dream
pass to get into local transport which
you uh could have just gone on that if
you had a um if you had a negative test
uh before a couple of days ago so uh
well more restrictive measures here
ahead of the christmas holidays and new
year's eve
thank you very much for the update thank
you chloe
did you know that air pollution isn't
just bad for the environment it's bad
for our health too
[Music]
ireland northern ireland wales and
southwest england will see heavy rain
and strong winds during the morning
although ireland will turn more showery
later there's a risk of disruption from
rain and gales scotland and northern and
eastern england will be fine it'll be
cold there milder in the very windy
southwest
northern and eastern britain will see
prolonged rain and possibly damaging
winds later with potentially disruptive
snow
over northern hills while the unsettled
conditions will keep pollution levels
low with the air quality index between
two and three
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
almost a million women have retired
early because of the menopause putting
the country at risk of a pensions crisis
a government adviser has warned let's
talk about it in more detail andy briggs
the government's business champion for
older workers joins us now as you can
see hello to you mr briggs women
retiring early because of the menopause
why
um so
there are four million women in the uk
aged 45 to 55 in employment and as you
write this aka one in five end up
leaving the workforce force as a result
of the symptoms of menopause
and and the key challenge here is this
is a topic that just isn't talked about
there's a very broad range of both
physical and mental symptoms that that
women are suffering going through the
menopause transition and we need to get
the topic talked about actively in the
workplace so that
adjustments can be made and they can
stay in the workforce because one of the
biggest challenges is that if someone
ages over 50 leaves the workforce they
are less likely than any other age group
to come back into employment and that
has a huge impact on them personally has
a huge impact on the businesses who lose
those skills and capabilities
so what should employers do to try to
make that not so
so so i'd say three core things that
that we'd look for employers to do the
first is just to have this talked about
in the workplace it isn't at the moment
every single woman in the workplace at
some point will go through the menopause
transition
the second is to look at all the
processes you have within a business
occupational health well-being champions
employee assistance programs and embed
the menopause transition within those
programs and then the third area is is
specific dedicated training for for
managers um so that they are equipped to
understand uh uh better uh what what the
menopause transition can involve and how
they should engage with the
the uh 40 and 50 year old women in the
workplace that might be going through
the menopause transition
okay thanks very much for the update
andy thank you sarah davis co-founder of
talking menopause also with us this
morning um hello to sarah the menopause
is nothing new why are we still in this
position
because unfortunately menopause is where
like maternity was in pregnancy about 20
years ago
none of us have grown up learning about
menopause it's a taboo subject it's a
myth
for so many really and so before that
reasons too many aren't aware of what
the impact of menopause is the symptoms
the challenges and it is a long-term
hormone deficiency and as andy just said
too many women are unnecessarily
suffering and
also too many colleagues shy away from
talking about it unfortunately i've
worked with women from you know judges
and barristers who have hot flushes or
brain fog moments in
a woman who works for a large nhs trust
emailed us after an online conference
and said
um thank you for the bottom of my heart
i am black i am bald-headed i'm 58 we
don't talk about it in our communities i
am now shouting from the rooftops about
my brain fog and my menopause
oh yeah welcome to the club sister now
why is the menopause given that not a
protected characteristic under the
equality act
very good question they're talking about
it becoming a protected characteristic
it is covered under age and sex i think
it might and we talking menopause with
my um business partner linda bailey who
used to work at west midlands police we
think it should be a protected
characteristic like maternity is it
could also be currently perceived as a
disability under the equality act
which is important for managers and
employers to be aware of
yeah um i know that the uh the commons
women and equalities committee have
opened an inquiry into the menopause i
think i'm right in saying that
what do you hope to come from that
well carolyn harris the mp who's been
leading the all-party parliamentary
group has been amazing
a number of things one thing is to
hopefully remove the cost of hrt in
england it is being reduced because too
many women are being denied hrt for this
long-term hormone deficiency sadly a lot
of women being offered antidepressants i
had a women on an online cafe last week
i was running who for the first time had
opened up was crying in front of her
colleagues she used to be a ceo
of an organization
and she's been offered antidepressants
and she's no she's not depressed so
certainly
general awareness
improved guidelines practical solutions
in the workplace improved medical
training for healthcare professionals
incredibly important
and also to make sure it's instilled in
the school curriculum my daughter's
actually who's 16 is going to help her
school with a menopause lesson for her
pshe curriculum
fantastic and a quick shout out to james
timson before i let you go from timson's
explain why um he's our hero at the
moment
because he's kindly offering currently
free hrt or currently offering to pay
for the prescription charges for hrt for
all his employees which is wonderful
that's amazing isn't it because it's not
free um on as a prescription in england
although it is in other parts of the
union
wells in scotland it is free yeah and in
england it isn't and actually for some
individuals uh including myself we can
have three or four products so you have
to pay three or four prescription
charges so for a lot of women it will
save over 200 pounds a year and it must
have been forgotten there are a lot of
women struggling poverty-wise in certain
socio economic groups that just don't
have access or financial means to get
hrt
sadly we're out of time but it's always
really important to highlight the
menopause brush on the carpet for too
long thank you very much indeed for
updating us thanks a lot
yes freezing cold in my studio and that
really helps me thanks to the team see
you at 8.
[Music]